what's up ladies and gentlemen ryan
right over here we the real reject o's
have hit 100,000 subscribers do you know
what that means i'm a youtube sensation
i am part of the big leagues now i am
what you call popular amongst high
school children because the primary
demographic of this channel are high
schoolers who lie and say they're 18
years old to watch videos like mine on
youtube so thank you high school kids i
hope you appreciate all the racism dick
jokes and sexist jokes but no seriously
thank you guys so much you guys have
been wonderful throughout all the
personal life struggles I've had to go
through because out of all that over the
past two years you guys have been the
one consistent thing that has never
failed to like bring me up without you
guys like I really wouldn't be as
chipper as I am these days like I
continue to do these videos because you
guys encouraged me to keep going you
guys encouraged me to keep doing stuff
so really big thank you to you guys so
[ __ ] much i'm not just saying that I
don't want to cry again I just cried a
lot of video thank you thank you thank
you thank you gosh and you know what we
need more female subscribers so why
don't you guys start setting these
videos to females as we need more female
subs it's lonely here without some
female demographic putting that channel
trailer together thank you guys for
submitting all your videos sorry cut off
line already but thank you guys for
submitting all your videos I'm going to
make sure to include you guys in our
channel trailer the top 30 regardless
i'm doing a fan compilation so if you're
not on the channel trailer you will be
in this other video for sure and Tyrone
Magnus I know you have more subs than me
you better look out you big beautiful
black man so I'm coming at you so is gay
or Martin kind of scared of Gator Martin
here's my Gator Martin impression he has
right just for you gets oh snap damn oh
[ __ ] here's my tyro Magnus impression
yo I'm a big beautiful black [ __ ] yeah
anyway that's the reactor world for you
guys hundred thousand subs let's get to
another hundred thousand people what
about a million oh my god oh my god
program to see stuff and you can follow
us on Facebook Instagram and Twitter
social network plug and uh yeah praise
be to God and Buddha or what are those
Jews believe in it's like the patient